[Music]
[Applause]
all right well the raiders returned to
the scene of the crime this sunday for
only the third time since
2001. raider nation will tell you it was
that dreadful day at gillette stadium
that changed the course of raiders
history was something known as
the tuck rule game
[Applause]
raiders were leading the patriots in the
2001 afc divisional playoff game with
under two minutes to go
charles woodson makes a move strips tom
brady and the raiders recover
it's over but wait he did fumble that
damn ball
no it wasn't it was ruled that brady was
tucking the ball
no fumble patriots go on to win one play
one call and one huge mistake changed
the course of nfl history
the rule was abolished in 2013. anytime
you step in a stadium like that
it does bring back memories and some of
the memories aren't great
derek carr was about nine years old
he'll never forget that game
that's the big moment in just football
history let alone raider history
and patriot history you know and so
definitely had a lot of conversations
about it
you know as a raider fan of course it's
a fun board car heads back to the scene
of the crime for a second time he was
there as a rookie in 2014.
and we went down and scored and then we
had a holding penalty that gets called
back and then the next play
ball bounces off my guy vince wolf picks
it off so i don't have good memories
there either you know
so i got a got a lot of making up to do
but i'm excited for the opportunity
oh still bitter hey we'll see if the
raiders can snap along losing streak in
new england the last time they won there
was a 1994 that's when the raiders were
playing in los angeles and jeff
hostetler was a quarterback and
tim brown was making a name for himself
these young
raiders weren't even born the last time
they won at new england
now they got to carry some momentum into
gillette stadium